نعم بالفعل اعلن عن استشهاد الاسير عبد
الرحمن باسم البحش من مدينه نابلس بعد
يعني عامين من سجنه حيث اعتقل في ال 31 من
ايار لعام 2002 وحكم عليه انذاك بثلاثه
اعوام امضى منها عامين لكن الاحتلال قام
باعدامه مساء هذا اليوم ليتم الاعلان عن
استشهاده من قبل نادي الاسير والمؤسسات
الدوليه وحقوق الانسان نحن الان نتواجد في
داخل منزل الشهيد حيث نلتقي مع والد
الشهيد الاستاذ باسم البحش بدايه عمي عظم
الله اجركم اي كيف يعني تلقيتم خبر ارتقاء
عبد الرحمن وكيف كان وقع عليكم والله انا
كنت موجود قاعد
بالمق طبعا بعد ما بروح من شغلي
جاني تليفون من الحجه تعتي من امه بتقول
لي بقولوا في اسير مستشهد في
مجده نفس
الاوصاف اللي وصفوها
لعبود على انه عمره 24 سنه وتهمته كذا
وكذا وكذا نفس
الوصف فقلت لها بشوف ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله ما يكون هو يعني بتعرف الواحد بيتمنى
دائما البقاء لاولاده وحبايبه والموت
علينا حق وهذه الشهاده انا بعتز فيها
لابني لانها الله اصطفاه الحمد لله رب
العالمين والشكر لله
ف قلت لها تاكدوا انتم اكثر على التلغرام
شاي
كيف
وبالفعل قلت له هيني جاي طلعيت انا وابني
على الدار
هون طلعت هيك بقول له انت جوز من تاكد لي
يعني اذا الخبر يجوز شاعه والى اخره قالوا
لا في واحد ذكرنا اسم ثاني
يعني فقلت له لا انت شوف خلص طبعا اتصل في
كنا في نادي الاسير واحدى الجهات يعني
اللي لها خاص
بال
بالمساجين او
في اي نعم كعائله اليوم يعني كيف بتنظر
لجرائم الاحتلال المتواصله لا بد من جرائم
الاحتلال لانهه وسائل كثيره في
الاجرام وحسب ما بنسمع من خلال
اي ما يكون هناك سجين يعني بين اربع
حيطان ومن خلال التعذيب والضرب والبتش ب
بالمساجين والتعريه اللي بروهم اياها
تنسيش بالسعه
وبنوهم شايف كيف ننوم ما فيش ايك زي الناس
ما فيشي هذه توصيه الصهاينه ابن غفير هذه
توصيه شايف كيف زلال من المساجين لكن هن
ان شاء الله ما رايحين ينزلوا بموت ولده
احرار وان شاء الله بعيشوا احرار والشهيد
يما بيستشهد عند ربه بستشهد حر الحمد لله
رب العالمين رافع راسه بشهادته شايف كيف
ولذلك هذا كاس على كل الناس واحن بنفا انه
ابنا استشهد والله اطفى للشهاده ربنا وهذا
عريس والحمد لله رب العالمين ولا حول ولا
قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم شكرا شكرا لك
يعني على هذه التفاصيل اذا يعني هذه رساله
والد الشهيد ويعني بهذا الشهيد يرتفع عدد
شهداء الحركه الاسيره الى
244 شهيدا ومنذ السابع من اكتوبر الى 100
الى عفوا سبعه شهداء في وضع صحي ومعاناه
متواصله للا داخل سجون الاحتلال